so
take us to latin america take us to that
to that time and and also
when you switched over from city to
another firm on another coast right city
and i talked to you about marine midland
and then
this is now we are going back to 1982
august of this that year the mexican
officials were coming to the federal
reserve bank of new york to say
we are bankrupt we can't make any debt
payments anymore
and marine midland the way it was
countries don't go bankrupt yeah they
don't go bankrupt right
i think 140 broadway where we were
you can look diagonally across at the
federal reserve bank of new york
entrance and you saw this whole team of
cars part
and mexican officials whom you recognize
by sight they're all going into the
building wow you knew something was so
if you did a one of those peter lynch
type
shoe leather research you would know
something is dreadfully wrong
um so
wait one did you say 140 broadway 140
broadway that's where i first
interviewed a dlj
that's right so it's looking at that and
six months later it became clear to me
this is what an economist does in
long-term forecasting i said this is not
one of the short-term issues you're
facing this is going to be a long-term
problem
and i said i'm becoming a consultant
and he looked at me and said only people
who are fired become consultants
[Laughter]
it shows you how the world has changed
you you don't need to become a
consultant
and so think about it for two weeks and
come back
so i went um
just spent five days and i said i don't
need two weeks i've spent five days i'm
becoming consultant
zero client base
but what helped was the auditing firm
which was auditing marine midland i went
to them and appealed to them and said
look
you are auditing different money center
banks there then there was also other
banks like jp morgan chemical bank
manufacturers hanover
and even though you do that you don't
have an assessment of the countries and
how much the assets are worth i'm not an
accountant or a financial person
but i can give you the macro background
to it
and you can use that essentially to show
the regulators you're taking adequate
care in assessing
your clients portfolios right this is
this is your due diligence your risk
assessment
and it clicked and they became my first
client started with zero within about
two months i had that
and then thereafter another auditing
firm which uh audited the rest of the
new york city bank they found out well
they are hiring you as a consultant we
don't want to be left out without it i
got hired again there was no conflict of
interest i'm giving you country
information
so i could do both
and then soon enough i was audited i was
working for three of the then big eight
accounting firms
that got me started
then i had a few regional banks who
became clients so in the first year my
total intake revenue was just five
thousand dollars
but in the second year i was making more
money than my bank job
and it was very enjoyable and drexel
burnham had just started a dead trading
group out of beverly hills
and the person who was there wanted help
in also getting advice on what what to
do about it
so i started and after the first meeting
the second time he said can we meet a
few minutes before our meeting begins
said sure we met and he said how about
closing up your shop and coming and
meeting a person called michael milken
and i said oh i've heard his name i've
seen his name in newspapers
and so they said get on a flight and
come and the rest of it is history 1986
onward i've been on the west coast
[Music]
you